I'm a bot based on the opening book of
Chess streamer and international Master
Eric Rosen challenge me and see if you
can take down my Stafford Gambit or
London system okay
let me challenge you read it five two
should I have done one read it
it's
27.94 oh wow
wait that's stronger than me
okay
uh is it gonna play a Stafford
wait this is so exciting
I'm playing robot me
Stafford let's refute the Stafford
Gambit
I'm scared it knows Theory but I also
know Theory
so it's following my opening look
wait what's gonna happen
yeah I I knew you're gonna do that I'm
gonna play the magical line
wow
this is all still Theory now the move I
like to play here is Bishop F3
can I just farm this for a reading if it
just plays a Stafford
is it saying anything
okay I think we're live
I sometimes say that in the beginning of
streams
we'll play Bishop F3
oh it's playing this line
so if I fork
It's Tricky
all right let's play this first
and then I fork
I think it's out of book now that's
starting to think
oh it's playing a refuted opening
yeah I used to play this move with idea
that after
like if white plays E5 there's takes
takes takes Bishop G2 Bishop G4 and like
black has already having almost full
compensation
but H3 really kills this whole variation
can I trash talk it
Oh no you're opening
I don't know if it will talk to me
though
yeah big shout out to Leo Spaceman who I
believe
like made this whole thing
um
okay let's uh let's win material now
I feel like I'm in pretty good shape
I missed opportunity to play the role
doesn't wait I'm not winning material
oh yeah no Bishop D7 unfortunately
I guess I'm not winning material
but I'll have a pleasant position
I mean I can play this move
I'm pretty sure it plays my opening and
then it's basically stockfish after the
opening
so I wonder if it can salvage uh this
position
really I can play this move
oh it's not simple though Knight F7 wait
takes Knight F7 defending attacking
attacking
do I have to play this
it's already like really not so simple
I think F4 is probably the best way to
justify all of this
is developing my pawns before my pieces
I guess it's not trash shocking in the
chat that is trash talking with its
moves
oh which I do
I like how it's taking time though I
would take time in this position as well
all right I think I should take with
this Pawn
not allowing any bishop move
this Pawn chain restricts the bishop
wow it's castling
almost forgot that was legal
but I can
I can take the knights
there's a crazy line takes takes takes
Queen E3 Queen E2 Queen G3 King lose
Rook F2
oh that's super dangerous
maybe I should just trade Queens
I think I should just trade Queens
okay I'm still up a pawn
so takes takes
Bishop H6 Knight D2
let's take here first
and then Knight T2
no need to rush with a queen trade
it's taking a weird amount of time here
because it should be an automatic
capture unless I guess this was an
option too
King h8 so now if I want to trade Queens
here's the moment
I think I do
and then King E2
yeah the real me would pre-move Bishop
takes E6
sometimes this is how you can tell if
you're playing a bot if it takes time on
like a automatic recapture
oh dear just blunder
I have this move
it's not so simple though
Bishop here
we trade
C5 wow
it's playing good moves
bishopath three
okay now at least Rook G1 will defend
I'm a little bit scared of this this and
then C5 again
I don't have Rook F1 because Bishop C4
I have king of King E3
maybe Rook G1 no Rook G1 hangs upon
I'm scared maybe this move
the position seems very delicate though
like I'm still up a pawn but it has a
bishop pair open files
C5
I'm hit again
if I take
I actually don't fully understand
the Knight D6 is maybe coming
ah rookie five
oh dear
I'm in trouble
I've before
okay let's
I feel like I'm in trouble now
rookie one
or maybe Rook C1
just gotta get my Rooks involves
it's not taking my Pawn
man this is absolutely terrifying
it's still not taking the pawn it wants
more
Rook E3 Maybe
rookie three
take take
oh no my time
no that doesn't work
okay Rook E3
I regret trash talking this
oh no
take Take Ah
maybe G4
can G4 save me
it's a counter attack
and if takes takes H5 opens
oh good move
take take
oh no
don't hurt me
that's probably not gonna listen
if it were truly me it would say no
mercy
or it just probably ignores me and yeah
I'm about to be finished
it's crazy though how it's not like it's
not simplifying immediately
and leaving my Rook to suffer
playing with its food
I feel so pinged right now
oh yeah I would have chat disabled
okay
can I trick it into cell mating me let's
give away all the pawns and then
maybe I can achieve some stalemate
let me at least try one cell Matrix
but what would that involve putting the
king here
now it's taking its sweet sweet time
I need the bishop to come
okay oh I got mated
someone calling it ambulance but not for
me oh it's so Savage
I just got thrashed
I thought I knew the refutation of the
sapphire gambits
E5 doesn't win a piece
what should I do wrong
I lost a stronger AI version of myself
oh no my career I'm probably gonna be
replaced by a bot
someone just needs to program like a
a trained AI of my
my voice and like have an AI Avatar of
basically the Bots combined with my
voice explaining the moves
and I'll be completely replaced I don't
know what I did wrong though
like after casting it was already a
little bit questionable because I was so
behind the development man that was just
like a slow
and then quick downward slope
so I still had the advantage but I lost
it very gradually
it made three inaccuracies oh all in the
opening
it was following my opening tree
yeah the cool thing is I can see my my
opening tree here so it's following
the games I've played from this position
as black
I played 71 games from this position
[Music]
I was following a game I played against
Gary
if oh wow he's five is uh inaccurate
and Bishop E3
maybe for choice
as a winning position according to the
engine
wasn't so easy though
okay that was fun I'll have to put that
on YouTube